hey my name is that's my name
I'm here with Danny DeVito we're gonna
play come close there don't be shy I
like to like see it we're going to draw
together so I'm going to draw and Danny
is going to guess what I'm drawing here
we go
I feel like four line for a nail I'm not
done yet
I see ground for marker for hockey stick
can you know I see camouflage for groom
or rifle be quiet
oh right now it's Golf Club now you got
it
congratulations okay now we're going to
draw a paintbrush this is very exciting
I see line 44 string bean we love room
I'm not you're a I'm not done
alright I'm so much I see shovel I'm
cotton boy nice boy your driver
be quiet low I be clarinet I'm going on
an island
I see Denise off I'm still drawing sorry
I couldn't guess it that's too bad you
tried really hard
draw a sucker ball and under okay join
in soccer ball
I should be easy I see line for nose I
see potato for circle hey that's not a
potato
I see fake or bread for bracelet oh boy
helmet I see bear or mouth how did you
feel bear we're done what are you on
about
sorry I couldn't guess it you [ __ ]
idiot Danny you're so stupid oh right no
it's mountain oh that was fast
that was fast radio okay I see diving
board for pillow for keyboard for bread
I see camera for math oh I know it's
radio okay that's pretty impressive
you're getting good at this Danny Colin
vision I see suitcase for elbow for
square or cooler I peed picture frame
I'm stumped
I'm comin for dresser for all run while
I pee pad for oh I know it's television
she got it I mean you got it well drawn
thank you
that was so fun Danny that was so fun
what a game I what a story drawn ax
d toothpaste or crayon or marker for
megaphone oh I know it's axe this is the
weirdest [ __ ] game wait what is it
with the drug sisters
I see frying pan for in for mosquito for
cows
I see snowman Ornette Coleman for a
young fan for muffin grapes for coffee
cup or Apple for eyeglasses it's clearly
a sorry I couldn't guess it well I guess
that robots aren't going to take over
anytime soon I see line I see marker or
knife or canoe or garden hose that's a
lot of canoe I see ocean or trombone for
animal a lot of [ __ ] what are you
focusing on Hayley I'm getting worried
about it we're dipping board for carrots
I see elbow for crocodile or bracelet or
hand I come on
sorry I couldn't guess it ah she was so
close I see moon or nose for potato four
circles job potato o clock oh she got
that damn well if you're gonna guess
every single [ __ ] thing ever
you can't just I should blend a little
oh I got it right
draw a dresser okay fine I see Golf Club
or suitcase for square for breast what
can i decline for one goddamn second app
for clocks
I see sandwich for pants that is not a
bad whack with popsicle
I see picture frame for telephone or the
Mona Lisa
I see passport or cooler come on
sorry I couldn't guess it I see diving
board for garden hose or bottle cap I
feed pillow or umbrella
that's the hexagon right sorry I
couldn't guess it
I see line or boomerang or elbow forearm
four fingers at the diving board for
screwdriver or bats
I see roller coaster for mustache or
toothpaste IPP for stitches for dogs or
fish for frogs I female or trumpet okay
yeah this thing is the best thing ever
it's so amazing I think you got a
program or a bought where I leave for
nose get the essential I feel like I see
rain I see jello I'm stumped
I'd say camouflage or laughter or zebra
that's a zebra you got it let's play a
different game
all right so this one is directly
connected to data dance mouse this is
the sound he's making you control I'm
controlling
Danny's throat right now
[Music]
yeah why is it so funny
oh very very very very very very very
very good good girl good girl should not
be this funny why am i laughing like a
maniac your director their director are
you saying something getting really good
you look very good really good order mmm
well that was fun
let's play a different game feels really
good alright final website that I want
to check out today is this is website
that lets you decide it decides if your
picture is awesome or not so let's see
right now if I am awesome or not 1%
percent chance 1%
[Music]
what about Jackson got them 0% you got
little Jackie instead of a [ __ ]
[Music]
33% mother oh my god you got 0% Jack
zero potential zero to buy whatever
African ethnicity got him
are you kidding me you can't be seeing
it how do you go from zero to 100 that
quick are you kidding me you can't be
fit this must be a coincidence all right
what about this picture you can't make
this [ __ ] up all right I think it's
probably for the better if we move on
from this one because it's not gonna
it's not going to be good it's already
it's already bad what else do we got
let's play a different game
okay I'm supposed to draw a lotion
why is it all blue the [ __ ] is half of
that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] bleep okay a lotion
lotion Wall Street Journal are you
[ __ ] kidding me
good guess so unguessed it ha ha ha ha
ha yes good job
thanks for nothing okay drawing the next
pot red ring of death it's time matter
latter box am I the only one oh that's a
chat xbox great we broke the website
excellent
that's fine I didn't want to have fun I
see spoon for fun for potato or
bracelets for peanuts I see steak or
frog for Mouse I see dogs or tree for
rain for crocodile for flying saucer
sorry I couldn't guess it I see line for
keyboard or cooler or belts for marker I
see hot dogs or bathtubs for anvil for
hamburgers I see pool or sink or
aircraft carrier or diving board
I see speedboats for submarines for
sandwich for fun sorry I couldn't guess
it flamingos a female for banana for
nose Force one for saxophone I see
snakes or peanuts or lollipop oh right
no it's flamingo hey you did it how
about that great this is too much fun I
see fingers for mountain or two i feet
grown
I have no clue what you're drawing shut
up [ __ ] it is alright shut up it's my
hand right now it's handed yes oh my god
so good at this game well that was fun
wasn't it I was did you Danny what are
you doing
did you have fun today wow that was that
was a good video definitely I hope you
enjoyed thank you for leaving a like and
support next time let's draw together
that will be fun I'm sure it will work
check out another video here if you
enjoy watching as always any support
that you leave is appreciated so thank
you really like and a comment and
subscribe and buy all my merch twice
thank you don't have any March don't
worry about it buy it anyway
brofist